where are you
there she is
you called for a drooper it's your lucky
date come on in
we're riding we're riding keep me
rolling by the way how about these
prickly legs and these old toenails that
I know you gotta get that little given
up online
up
it's a red light a red light red light
fashion all done
have you ever peed in a swimming pool
oh hell yeah I'd be in a swimming pool
that's so funny that Nicole asked that
question when I'm alone in my pool and
it's being filtered over and over with
also chemicals it's my pull yeah I want
to talk about body fluids for the rest
of our lives absolutely and be besties
and kick each other's butts and be there
in every big and small moment that life
has to offer
was there a moment that you knew that we
would be lifelongers I feel like we were
always moving towards it from the minute
we met and it was just like not apparent
until when Charlie's Angels when we were
like in the thick of it together where
we were just like this works knowing you
from 14 and 16. if anyone needs to like
be broken out of somewhere in the middle
of the night in a very of suddenly
remote location this is your girl
like but you will show up thanks poops
it takes one to no one where life is
oh oh red light compression all done
hold it what is the last text my husband
sent you oh let me see oh it was a house
listing of course I really do like surf
Zillow at night and then you know what
I've realized lately I'm really happy
right where I am that's amazing
I just got a question that came to my
head if you had to remake any movie what
remake would you make oh I don't know
that's a really hard question for some
reason I mean I know we're in a car and
I've talked to Adam Sandler about it I
just think Planes Trains an automobile
the two of us
let's do it yeah let's do it let's do it
why wouldn't we why wouldn't we I have a
mobile roommate
and it's Ronnie Ronnie tried your wines
and it is time for Ronnie's review last
night was a very good one tasting it was
wonderful the white wine I love the very
crispy note refreshing and oddly enough
I thought to pair it with a cheesecake
I have no idea why cheesecake white wine
pairing yes the red one was just Blended
perfectly rich in taste but it wasn't
too overpowering you know it made me
want another one and maybe a few more I
love this review yeah they're not like
intimidating minds they're just like
easy beautiful clean wine
last confession it's so funny one of
these questions is did you ever lie
about liking anyone that I've dated
you're incapable of doing that
I saw nothing with you like you're
incapable I could take a hard stance on
things but hey I can be persuaded if
it's like if you can give me a good
argument I would never lie about
somebody that you were dating I say that
I like them if I did not I know every I
know how you feel about everyone I've
dated
thank you so much for riding in the
drooper I love you I love you so much
[Music]
get to leave me a review
[Music]